foreign
and welcome to the show
hello can you guys hear me you sound
great yes
awesome hey I have a question
um my wife and I have gotten ourselves
in a in a really bad spawn uh so we have
about 250 000 in Consumer Debt that's
credit cards and personal loans
um
we're just not sure what to do we don't
have enough income to pay all of our
minimum payments and so we're not sure
if we should file bankruptcy or to stop
paying until we can afford to settle or
we're just not sure where to go from
here
what caused y'all to go 250 000 in
credit cards and personal loans
well it's everything you guys say not to
do we
decided I decided I should say to to
flip a house and then buy two more
houses with uh a lot of Leverage right
when interest rates went up and we ended
up taking a a really big bath on these
three properties we lost money on all
three of them I'm so sorry
um yeah it's uh it's definitely been
tough and uh and on top of that during
that time I was so focused on that that
uh I'm in real estate in my production
uh pretty much went to zero during that
time because my mine was just so wrapped
up in that
um
so that that's where we're at and uh
we're just really not sure where to go
from here how old are you guys
uh I'm 28 my wife is 27 we have a
two-year-old daughter and we have
another that's going to be arriving in
October oh my gosh
you know it's wild Brandon uh if you're
familiar with our my family's story that
little baby that's gonna be born that
was me and my sister was two years old
when my parents filed for bankruptcy
um and through real estate issues I mean
Dad did exactly what you did but on a
massive scale and they called all of his
notes and
he uh if he was sitting here today I
think his empathy would be at the
highest level because he was literally
you
um 35 years ago which is pretty wild so
um I I have such like a heart for those
kids and your kids and your wife and all
of it because I know you guys are under
a lot of stress and I know there's
probably a lot of yeah shame and
embarrassment and you feel a lot of the
weights
um
and so I hear I hear all of that so my
question would be how much how much did
you make when you were in real estate
and in your head was not all over the
place with these other rentals and you
were so focused on it what were you
bringing in
so I mean I would average probably
somewhere between nine and ten thousand
dollars a month uh my wife also works
she brings in about five to six thousand
dollars a month
okay and what is the case today what's
kind of the average month for you guys
so so right now she's still bringing
that five to six thousand a month
um I've just rededicated myself to real
estate
um as of last week so right now it's
it's nothing
um you know ideally in the next
if I'm realistic maybe 90 to 120 days
we're going to start seeing some fruit
from all the work I'm doing today okay
yeah Brenda I don't think you're not
you're not bankrupt
um but I would say catching up on those
minimum payments is your number one goal
and Brandon I I in your future here for
the next
probably two to three years you're going
to be doing more than just real estate I
mean you're gonna be doing side hustles
at nights you're gonna be exhausted
you're gonna be exhausted because the
amount of effort that you guys are gonna
put into this because I believe you can
to get out of this hole it's going to
take a lot and you're going to be really
uncomfortable
and you're gonna it's gonna feel like a
sacrifice because that's what's that's
what it's gonna take to get out of this
and you guys have to I was gonna say
promise US I mean more promise
yourselves that you align in the Santa's
drawn and for your kids sake you will
never ever go back to this again
that debt is off the table 100 because
if you keep dabbling it and Brandon I'm
telling you you're gonna go right you're
going to look up again you're gonna be
right back in this position so you guys
need a mindset shift you and your wife
and draw a black and white line and say
never again we're not doing this yeah
and for the next three years our our
lives are gonna look a whole lot
different and it's going to be really
hard with those babies at home but
Brandon
you're going to be able to do this you
guys are going to be able to to get out
of this but it's going to take a lot of
work and a lot of sacrificing your
lifestyle for it to put every penny
possible to go towards the step yeah
Brandon you said it was 250 total
yeah but I I do have kind of a wrench to
throw in it so
um I guess two questions number one is
total debt payments we have around 6 000
on top of uh living expenses of around
nine thousand
um so number one it's we're just not
sure like how do we actually cash flow
this thing like what do we let go okay
here's what I want to do Brandon I'm
gonna gift you guys Financial Peace
University and every dollar premium to
get on a plan but looking at the math on
this it's just a math equation can we
throw Seven Grand a month and be done in
36 months it comes down to something
that simple hang on the line we'll get
you those resources